peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
un mario
au moins quatre ans ivo de piqué tu
appelles et 11
à couches culottes avait les bons becs
dedans et lolita des fonds doivent nous
y un coup de râteau
dando
[Musique]
à 30 avant de faire emmerder par ces
petits machos qui pensent qu'à une chose
jouer au docteur non conventionnés j'y
jouais aussi je sais de quoi je cause
[Musique]
connaît bien les plus hautes des bacs à
sable dragué leur mère avant de
connaître la tienne si tu les écoutes
ils feront art et leur cartable
heureusement que je suis là que je te
regarde
que je t'aime
[Musique]
et lola
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
je suis gay
[Applaudissements]
tu sais
[Musique]
on est mardi
tatoué les machins
bande dessinée sur la peau
j'ai écris ton avec des clous dorés un
parent implanté dans le cuir de monts
candau
11 est ce que je peux tenir dans mes
bras sans d'émettre une épaule sans
plier sous ton voix
mèze moins lourd qu'un moineau qui
mangent pas mais toi jamais
cl lolita t'envoles pas à
délices de ra quo
il rêvait
az qui tape au plus secret qu'un pain au
chocolat turc le dos
enfin à
le petit mec quand ira à l'école
si jamais
il a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre tâche elle
généraux
et venez ça
magasin
crois pas
ta mère
à chaque fois
dans
ensemble
crois pas come on
déjà
[Musique]
en page bruit
grande soirée
tiens
hagard
mon art
l'aspect
[Musique]
son procès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais bien
[Applaudissements]